[Music]
for many church is not just a place to
worship
it's often a place where people gather
for information
and at this service the rollout of the
coronavirus vaccine
has made it into a sermon be careful
of these so-called prophets that are
going around talking to you telling you
that don't take the vaccine
because you know one thing if you don't
take that vaccine you will die
in some communities a culture of
mistrust combined with the speed of how
quickly the vaccine has been delivered
is fueling doubt this has made them to
distrust the government
and especially because of the way it's
been rolled out from what i've had
people have got concerned
there's something you know dodgy about
it
and as a result of it uh uh from my
point of view and also from what i've
heard from the people here is
that has played into the hand of the
people that are actually spreading
uh the news against where anti-vaccine
is concerned
the government has embarked on its most
ambitious vaccination program
it is the only way back to normality and
to secure
a future without lockdown for siva there
is a censor for worry
a recent study by the university of
oxford found that 12 percent of
people would not be vaccinated with a
further
16 saying they are hesitant you have to
weigh
up are you more scared of dying or are
you more scared of taking the vaccine
i was really really scared i was nervous
obviously but we're dealing with a
plague here
you know a real plague and i mean now
that
people were talking about a vaccine they
were sort of expecting a vaccine you
know and now that the vaccine is here
i believe that we really need to sort of
just come together and just trust in
that vaccine you know trusting
in the scientists this long-awaited
moment
may have provided hope to the nation but
in order for the vaccine to prove
effective
we all have to get behind it and
limiting the spread of covert 19 has now
become
synonymous with tackling the
misinformation and myths around a
vaccine
and in order to win the battle both must
be addressed
so why are people so skeptical it's a
question which is worrying experts
vaccine hesitancy is really
underestimated and very
dangerous in this respect because we
have these growing conspiracy theories
we have
alternative facts and information people
don't know where to turn
and as a result you know if there's a
growing number of people that are either
complacent
or you know um fall prey to some of this
misinformation the result is that we
just won't get this pandemic under
under control with coveted 19 cases
surging across the country
the vaccine seems to be a light at the
end of a very dark tunnel
and for the government they need to find
a way to connect with communities like
these
nel phillips sky news